[Musik]
kiefers ein dorf im deutschsprachigen
teil des kantons freiburg
idyllisch liegt die gemeinde im oberen
sensebezirk
viele einheimische befürchten dass es
bald vorbei sein könnte mit der ruhe
der bund will in der kugel einen gebäude
am rande der gemeinde ein asylzentrum
einrichten wird sich so oder so
verändere wie war ehrenmitglied willi
schreiner minister fox ist
[Musik]
wie die google als abgebrühter der
ruhige bruder helfen die diese
idyllische ruhe kleiderkammer und die
sie ohne information ohne nix hat diese
woche ist das kommt das asylzentrum
führung
plusminus asylbewerber haben
und die sieht diese fachärzte oder wie
sich einfach information per billion
[Musik]
wirtschaft der sensor ist nach wie vor
regionen der schweiz skeptisch muss ist
das unbedingt so
ich steh sitz nötig wenn das dem auf
etwa 105
wohin du dinge wo ich problemlos ging es
in die ich dass ich nicht gut
[Musik]
es ist februar 2015 der bund gibt
bekannt dass er das institut google ra
kaufen will und überrascht die
dorfbevölkerung mit der information dass
er dort ein dummes asylzentrum für 300
flüchtlinge einrichten will
die absichten des bundes stoßen im sense
oberland auf erbitterten widerstand
man feuer werden gezündet an vorderster
front mit dabei grossrat ruedi
vonlanthen langjährige ehemalige
gemeindepräsident von kiefers das hörer
so was man für sie als ort der freiheit
es geht einfach nicht dass der kanton
und der bund über betroffene bevölkerung
entscheiden
wir fühlen uns ohnmächtig und hilflos
und wer darf die politik kirche der
schweiz der gruppe entgegen
was sonst eher folkloristischen
unterhaltung dient ist an diesem abend
ein lautes zeichen des protestes
mehr als 1000 menschen sind in die
sporthalle von kiefers gekommen behörden
von bund und kanton haben einen
informationsanlass organisiert darf ich
den arbeitern aber ihre mini mehrere
gäste nicolas bürgisser ist der
oberamtmann des sensebezirks das
entspricht den anderen kantonen der
funktion eines regierungsstatthalters
bürger hat sich bereits im vorfeld als
befürworter des asylzentrums
positioniert sie noch fährt diskutieren
die fragesteller aber so wie wenn jemand
mit lohn machen möchtet ihr euch ja dass
ich denn nicht die einzige wasserquelle
wäre aber buffet vize-direktorin des
staatssekretariats für migration
versucht die bevölkerung zu beruhigen
erprobt die sicherheitskonzept muss ich
kein neuling auf dem gebiet um mit
krümmel
die stimmung im saal ist angespannt weil
der bund die google ra von einem
privateigentümer erworben hat gibt es
für die bevölkerung kein demokratisches
instrument um das bundesasylamt rum zu
verhindern
das projekt schmackhaft machen
wenn es so ist dass man das mir und
akzeptiere wir garantieren die ihre
sicherheit was maria suchst ihn soll
denn wenn kriminalität zunimmt wir für
die menschen im saarland die flüchtlinge
aber männer ist die politik
kulturbetriebes bayern oder andere acht
prozent verdienen waren sie um echte
flüchtlinge dass sie ihm andere war
etwas besser schleifer suche unser
sozialsystem wie und wo
problem war nach dem schloss als toto
oder jener händen
mache dir das nicht macht dann meinem
aber je nach eben selbst der
gemeindepräsident von kiefers greift zu
drastischen worten
der gemeindepräsident entschuldigt sich
einige tage später öffentlich für diese
aussage
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die cholera liegt auf einer dünn
besiedelten hochebene weitab vom
gießener dorfleben und doch fürchten
sich viele sängerinnen und sänger davor
dass hier bald bis zu 300 flüchtlinge
liegen sollen
dabei kennen die meisten einheimischen
die problematik rund um die migration
nur aus den medien auf die 1552
einwohner in käfers kommen 116 ausländer
im ganzen oberen sensebezirk beträgt der
ausländeranteil 7 prozent warum also
lösen die pläne des bundes eine solche
kontroverse aus
der sozialunternehmer wert fasnacht hat
das institut vor acht jahren gekauft er
hat das gebäude von den innen bola
schwestern die hier ein internat führten
für 10 millionen franken erworben wert
fasnacht betrieb darin ein
therapieprogramm für übergewichtige
kinder und jugendliche mit
schwierigkeiten bei der lehrstellensuche
weil bund und kanton die finanzielle
unterstützung kündigten habe er sich
gezwungen gesehen die google an den bund
zu verkaufen sagt er
das hätte sehr kurzfristig
außergewöhnlicher sie sehr schnell
fangen und im musée d'orsay motto der
wertschätzung gegenüber der asylbewerber
sehr stark sie das gebäude zur hofer
gedanken sicher win win situation zu
lösen so gute lösung und für sehe es
gebäudegröße wofür mehr
zu groß ist die 300 aus dem bewerbende
units bringen muss bestätigen
der herr was macht die der ufa probiert
fünf braucht vom bund im kanton an der
informationsveranstaltung musberg
fasnacht heftige kritik einstecken
insbesondere vom ehemaligen
gemeindepräsidenten ruedi vonlanthen
der grund und boden hat alle mal weg sie
jetzt ausgerechnet das aliabad fasnacht
jeweiligen versenkte emotionslos berufe
und problem vom kanton opel im verbund
lösen
daran nimmt also fünf verständnis
wer fasnacht versucht seinen verkaufs
entscheid zu rechtfertigen
[Applaus]
danke das standlicht native zum
geburtstag
bedürfen hochtief es belastet mich noch
mit true dick und aus dem bett aus
profiteur herrschte großartig fordert
macht methodik an ihnen die stars wohnen
die letzten acht jahre habe der regel
gleich aus 60 ansicht ist es so dass die
arbeiten und erbrecht hat die millionen
verloren muniz autos galten investiert
es ist effektiv und es geht wichtig mit
einer cholera und ich bin überzeugt dass
es weh tut muss euro fehlen einer wagt
es für den ehemaligen google ra besitzer
das wort zu ergreifen was der herr phase
auch beate machte die letzte jahr ist
grandios dass es ungerechter weise stars
gar nicht bewusst
und das ist eigentlich schaut will
erhält von böser junge mütter region
kanto ausserkantonale der schwester
besucht sagen und das ist lästig das
muss sehr genau machen
wer ist dieser mann der sich nicht
scheut gegen die vorherrschende meinung
stellung zu beziehen
wir finden ihn auf 1500 metern über meer
auf der alb stoß
mauritz böschung sorgt hier für die fast
300 kühe die auf den beiden weiteren
verteilt sind an den informationsabend
vom februar 2015 hat er keine guten
erinnerungen
[Musik]
das boot kenterte vor allem vom oberen
bezirk aber das ist ohne dies zu wissen
stimmt dinge die du also wie denn da ab
griffig wie es heißt also wie finde ich
den arm aber es ist wichtig oder wie
viel ich hoffe aber dass buße ist nicht
unbedingt das auch
[Musik]
die weiten wege zwischen seinen
alpweiden meister der albert am liebsten
joggend moritz böschung gilt als
querdenker
er hält mit seiner meinung nicht zurück
und provoziert gerne vor jahren hat er
im wolfs kostüm den abzug aufgemischt
moritz boschung polarisiert auf seine
alb sind in den letzten jahren mehrere
brandanschläge verübt worden
die täterschaft konnte bis heute nicht
ermittelt werden er sagt viele
einheimische seien sich nicht mehr
bewusst dass sie vor geraumer zeit in
einer ähnlichen situation waren wie die
heutigen flüchtlinge wie sehr sie sind
im sensebezirk automatismus wanderer die
ganze spitze die ganze weile uci oder
600 aber hier müsse gar wie sie nicht
ich erlebe hier nicht die reine
überleben und das relativ schnell
vergessen oder oecd geht es sehr gut
wer heute als zentrum der herr und wie
sie es ist nicht dass wir das zentrum
sind es heißt also ich einfach darum
gegangen dass ich ein shake wild roh als
rund ohne vorinformation ohne diskussion
und das ist moser wahrscheinlich nicht
sagte sie ja einige recht heftige
reaktionen zu dieser ohnmacht geselle
sich die angst vor dem verlust der
identität und von werten wie sie
beispielsweise christliche symbole
darstellten
[Applaus]
lästig
das die unterste schublade jena nord
religion die beziehung
und wenn ich sehe wie sie praktisch leer
ausgegangen sei es sich mit dem essen
und mit mitte mit der rechte turm mit
dem wenig mehr guten zahlen anderer der
beerdigung gab es in ms und eigentlich
sie dann als heftige veranstaltung auf
haye liegt umsätze sowie den ort
manipuliere mit der religion und das ist
natürlich dass ich die absolut dürftigen
platzieren will
das ist bitter so emotionales wo man
merkt dass die leute hier garnicht wirst
wenn du mal sieht klatsche in dem moment
wo der das gesicht mit dem schritt aber
es ist einfach quatsch oder was sagt
ruedi vonlanthen dazu wir treffen ihn an
einem heimspiel des fc kiefers
als ehemaliger spieler und
schiedsrichter fiebert er mit seinem
fußballklub mit der dieses spiel nach
einem rückstand noch gewinnt
[Applaus]
immerhin sieht man hier in einer
schlichten wie sie in einer katholische
gehen wäre sie noch nicht ob ich
vielleicht gegenüber der andere liegt
wohl vor allem gesät was verliert hier
seit der havarie war bis kuba aber nicht
unbedingt oeser wo vor allem ist er
verachtete der welt denen natürliche
baustoff beharren dass michael hawelka
palazzi und vor allem dass herr
gottfried städte also vom tag wieder hin
[Musik]
das kreuz auf der kugel war ein sinnbild
für den wert christlicher symbole im
sensebezirk die religion spielte hier
stets eine wichtige rolle
während jahrzehnten war die gegend stark
von der katholischen kirche geprägt
beten dienen und gehorchen lautete die
devise
[Musik]
armut und misere schweißten das sensor
volk zusammen
die tiefe gegenseitige solidarität ist
auch heute noch spürbar
[Musik]
die sammlerinnen und sammler galten als
heimatverbunden und lebenslustig sie
pflegten ein vielfältiges brauchtum
diese heile welt galt es gegen jede art
fremde einflüsse zu schützen
erst mit dem bau der autobahn bern
freiburg in den 1960 er jahren und nach
etlichen zu zögern vor allem aus dem
bernbiet begann sich der bezirk zu
öffnen
im sensor oberland hält die kritik am
ehemaligen google ra besitzer bierfass
nacht weiter an
der pensionierte steuerbeamte william
baby recherchiert in seinem keller büro
tage lang um angebliche ungereimtheiten
im zusammenhang mit dem verkauf der
google ra aufzudecken
darum ruft steht was davon machen
schaffte das um das gibt es mir für
seine vorwürfe hat william baby
allerdings keine belege
er ist das sprachrohr der ig google
einer interessengemeinschaft die dem
geplanten asylzentrum kritisch
gegenübersteht
er wies vorwürfe finden innerhalb der
interessengemeinschaft großen anklang
wieso die tour fahre was mich die
öffentlichen gelder vom bund und kantone
kurve passiert ist da vielleicht
querfinanzierung mit der kinder zwischen
die private und die offizielle firmen
bank um aufmerksamkeiten schöner habe
herr bis gut
mit dem verkaufserlös habe er nichts
verdient sondern schulden und
investitionen zurück bezahlt die er mit
der google ra auf sich genommen habe
sagt werth fasnacht es ist traurig dass
sich die sache hormon das betrifft mio
macht mir betroffen
dir wird wissen ganz genau wie viel sie
unter sie millionen-boni hier investiert
und die 19 millionen wohne jetzt
bekommen die entsprechen hieß der letzte
die hier investiert
die informationsveranstaltungen giffers
los bei den sängerinnen und sängern eine
heftige debatte um ihr selbstverständnis
aus in unzähligen leserbriefen in der
lokalzeitung freiburger nachrichten
bringen sie mit dem bild das sie an
diesem abend abgegeben haben
im zentrum der kritik steht ruhe die von
landen
besonders sauer stößt vielen
leserbriefschreibern auf das er am
informationsabend das sensor lied
angestimmt hatte
es handelt von der bitte an gott in der
not eine mauer um irland zu errichten
[Musik]
dieses lied ist auch ein halbes jahr
später an der selmer sind tafers ein
heiß diskutiertes thema unter den
lokalen politikern außenhandel die
betriebsstelle geschafft ja ja andere
schneuwly grossrat der freien wähler
liefert sich mit seinem bürgerlichen
kontrahenten einen offenen
schlagabtausch
zufällig begegnet sp präsident christian
levrat den streitenden
politik ist manchmal die gemüter zu
beruhigen nicht ausreichend verstanden
diese distanz staaten sind dann sagen
die hersteller hätten so die fw mit
lösungen kommen und da können sie
beruhigen und nicht sofort um die
ahndung nachmachen lassen
das ist das problem lösungen nicht
einfach rechts neben beamten für das
cool dass ich die bekannte diskussion
man gegen geführt sie probieren einfach
auf die tränendrüse zu drücken sie
einfach einmal das leder ganze welt die
flüchtlinge und somit das bloß nicht
vorzeigen das klavier sei überfordert
ich auch besser so dass wir das müsse
überhaupt bleibe aber da wir eine ganze
weile die politik kann man riege der
stars die rennanalyse oder university
ist also wieder raus
[Musik]
derart abzug in plaffeien
je näher das bedrohliche fremde rückt
desto mehr stehen für viele menschen
traditionelle werte im vordergrund
[Musik]
der alpabzug vereint brauchtum und
heimatliebe ernährt die sehnsucht nach
einer heilen friedlichen welt fernab
aller flüchtlingsdramen
das eintauchen in diesen mythos lässt
wenigstens für kurze zeit die
unsicherheiten der globalisierten welt
außen vor bleibt aber das gemeinsame
motto endlich klarheit zwischen den
autobots die auch die generationen mit
den über generationen zusammen
[Musik]
moritz böschung treibt die größte vier
herde ins tal
mit dieser mythischen heimatliebe hat er
aber wenig am hut
thematisch mir nicht das ist ein
typischer schweizer oder mit europäer
hätten darum wieder von klasnic zu
verbringen
ja nicht der joburg materie kommunen die
halt das glaubensbuch früchten fehler
wiederholt auf granit oberste pflicht ja
was ist dass ich das ganze beschädigt
das geht nur dort essig die jugendlichen
etwas ist eine hochverfügbare schlecht
geht geht es eben erschienene vier bösem
oberlahn aber schon recht große schicht
große schiff verließ nova populist
allawi wurde zusätzlich das problem
ähnlich wie ausblenden
wo war die helle mitte schweizerisches
und und und morgen kommt und chocolat
und darum bezogen
da sind wir als ich in die verlage
im februar 2016 trifft für die kritiker
des bundes asylzentrums das
schlimmstmögliche szenario 1
der bund erklärt die google hat zum
ausreisezentrum das bedeutet hier werden
jene asylbewerber leben die keine chance
auf ein bleiberecht und auf integration
haben sie warten hier auf ihre heimreise
viele von ihnen frustriert und empört
über die schweiz das alles weckt in der
bevölkerung ängste der große
proteststurm bleibt jedoch aus ein
meinungsumschwung in tafers bildet sich
die gruppe flüchtlinge willkommen im
sensebezirk sie versteht sich als
gegengewicht zur asyl kritischen haltung
in teilen des sense oberlandes die
gruppe möchte hilfs und
unterstützungsangebote an die
zukünftigen flüchtlinge machen und dazu
beitragen dass sich die fronten rund um
das asylzentrum nicht weiter verhärten
der mito unverdient zum beispiel von
friedrich am morgen das schild vom
oberland war sei es ist gut dass machen
rät mietern oder war wirklich berührt
sein stellte serie wie sie da
diskutieren
das navi kontakt zu brands
die gruppe ist daran sich intern zu
organisieren da noch nicht bekannt ist
wie die betreuung der asylbewerber in
der google organisiert sein wird bewegt
sich die diskussion aber noch im
luftleeren raum
ende april reist bundesrätin simonetta
sommaruga in den bezirkshauptort tafers
bundesweite sport ausmacht ja
bundesrätin sommaruga soll die neu
gewählten gemeinderäte vereidigen
doch ihr ist etwas viel wichtiger dass
der rahmen für das bundesasylamt rum in
kiefers ich habe lange vor meiner zeit
des bundes wegen eben als
gemeinderätinnen könig selber auch eine
asylunterkunft eröffnet und dabei die
erfahrung gemacht die fast alle machen
es ist schwierig es gibt widerstände bis
die unterkunft eröffnet ist und ich sie
dann einmal eröffnet dann lösen sich die
befürchtungen fast immer in luft auf und
ich hoffe dass sie das hier auch so
erleben es ist mir eine große ehre und
auch eine freude ihnen heute hier im
sensebezirk die größe und die
glückwünsche der landesregierung zu
überbringen
jetzt nicht so genau mit diesem einst
präsident gefragt wird der sätze haft
und ein filmisches denkmal gekommen ist
in dem strache jetzt kommt das langsam
verformen als höchst durch die beste was
auf uns zukommt und ich danke ich genau
der prozess etwas braucht was braucht
offenheit vor allem aber sicher klar
wenn wir nur mitgefühl hat überall aber
nicht böse sachen wir nicht weiter und
ich danke also funktioniert meinte dass
wir diesen staat als lieferant durch die
ganze pfarrgemeinde
sie konnte ein student
[Musik]
die eigene treffsicherheit
perfektionieren um sich im notfall gegen
unerwünschte eindringlinge zur wehr
setzen zu können sich miteinander messen
ware kameradschaft erleben dafür steht
das alljährliche feldschiessen
[Musik]
glock selbst als präsident des
freiburgischen schützenvereins ist rudi
vonlanthen dem schießsport in besonderer
weise verbunden
zusammen mit oberamtmann nicola
bürgisser tritt er zum wettschießen an
halt hier sonst wächst vom ganze jahr
als tradition durch zurufe gründe
naturschützer und seine apps dreher wir
die vorstopper der insel mehr hämische
can use land kennen alle bewerber das
frauchen willst also also das hat mit
dem direkt mit stehe aber nun mal da wie
das projekt organisiert kommt darum sie
auch kinder oder andere davon ein
anderer kanton oder um ist immer
natürlich und rosa
das gemeinsame wird schiessen verbindet
die waffe symbolisiert stärke
eigenständigkeit freiheit waffe
informiert in erster linie sportgerät
aber er will italien statt waffe in show
dar wenn man es ihm jetzt die besucher
im notfall verteidigen mit der waffe wie
es verteidiger wird vater lars von dort
verlangen der tropenkrankheit stelle
gegen flüchtlinge zu bespielen also das
ist jetzt natürlich gerade pizza fragt
warum spitzte sich momentan nicht statt
aber die birdies militär grenzen stelle
für zweifel im grenzwachtkorps zweifel
aber natürlich nicht vergessen ein gutes
resultat ist für den schützen
präsidenten rudi vonlanthen ehrensache
drittbeste gewähren ohren geschlagen
[Musik]
als erfahrener schütze entscheidet wo
die vonlanthen das sportliche mit
schießen gegen nicola bürgisser für sich
jaja das geplante asylzentrum
beschäftigt die von landen auch während
des feldschiessen so wird das sieht doch
gar nicht da sie dass sie aus einer
abgewiesenen das ist außerdem müsste der
grenze
das hat nicht immer recht schutzlücke
[Musik]
unterhalten werden die festbesucher von
den drei österreichern des trios
wolkenbruch ansonsten sind die sender
wie in alten zeiten praktisch unter sich
[Musik]
trotz widrigen wetterbedingungen findet
der gottesdienst am feldschiessen unter
freiem himmel statt
lasst uns beten der einfluss der
katholischen kirche hat abgenommen
dennoch hat die religion im sensebezirk
einen hohen stellenwert
die sängerinnen und sänger haben sich
daran gewöhnt dass neben dem
katholischen auch ein reformierter
pfarrer durch den gottesdienst führt mit
dem asylzentrum in kiefers werden
vermehrt muslime im sensebezirk leben wo
die vonlanthen kann sich vorstellen
diese unter gewissen bedingungen in die
religiösen zeremonien zu integrieren
das wäre ohne weiteres möglich neueste
musik wie sie immer aber immer
festlicher aber natürlich geschichte im
vordergrund dass die höchste kultur der
muslime ursprung immer ganz am anderen
ort in der welt dachte ich ja oder so
aber rettete er berät sie generell die
verschiedenen grobe als vereine fc vaduz
käme ja das war heute derweil temperatur
darüber dass als janney global jeder
mensch wasser wort aber an andere der
kriege anderen andere das harmonisch
machen wenn wir so viele ist das herz
und die augen aber oft ganz
überschritten
mit dem asylzentrum google wird der
sender oberland vermehrt mit fremden
kulturen in berührung kommen
das kann auch eine chance sein findet
oberamtmann nicola bürgisser weit
effektiver tagesschau sondern zur
realität meister hier wüste oder wir
beraten mieter als letzter hat
bundespolitikers wir suchen nicht nur
dass wir nur mit dem finanzausgleich
oder pc sondern dass wir aktuell
rückblick vor der bundesbehörde vom
bundesrat hat das sehr geschätzt
[Musik]
anfang oktober 2016 das zukünftige
bundes asylzentrum ist ziel eines
sabotageaktes
unbekannte dringen in das leerstehende
gebäude ein
sie manipulieren wasser hahnen sowie
abflüsse und verursachen damit auf
sieben stockwerken eine großflächige
überschwemmung
es entsteht ein sachschaden in der höhe
von 800000 franken
das ganze gebäude muss durch fachleute
getrocknet werden
das verzögert die umbauarbeiten der bund
reicht strafanzeige ein
von der täterschaft fehlt jedoch jede
spur einige tage später spekulieren
lokale politiker am harz american
giffers mit viel galgenhumor über die
urheberschaft des wasserschadens in der
google
der markt ist ein beliebter treffpunkt
der dorfbevölkerung eine plattform für
gewerbetreibende vereine und politische
parteien trotz aller kritik am
bundesasylamt rum verurteilen alle
seiten den sabotageakt in der kugel die
linksextreme ausgemacht dass wir die
zerstörte linksextreme oder 80 gesagt
und damit entsteht würdig dass sie jetzt
der wohnung die rechtsextreme machen
dass sie mögliche aber klipp offen zu
sein
am rande des märz betreibt die sp ihren
stand sie hat sich stets als
befürworterin des asylzentrums
positioniert die kritik am zentrum sei
abgeflaut sagt die sp der widerstand
habe sich auf eine andere ebene
verlagert das meer können die
jugendlichen und das ist sehr groß ist
rudi vonlanthen und nicola bürgisser
sinnieren derweil über ihre freundschaft
die seit jahrzehnten alle politischen
differenzen über dauert ja schon länger
die stuttgarter absolut aber das tut
frau numberger dem sie wirklich die
beste kollege die besten freunde
obwohl das moment dort da anderer
meinung sind die freundschaft ist
natürlich trifft medienpolitische
diskussion nicht gegen lich wenig sie
das ist ein guter sony würde sage das
ganz ehrliche freundschaft es gibt
andere freundschaften wo weniger
jährlich sie aber die freundschaft
gefährlich wir genannter offensichtlich
wenig sie anfang november haben die
beiden freunde grund zum feiern
in der dorfbeiz von kiefers stoß nicola
bürgisser und ruedi vonlanthen auf ihre
wahl ins freiburger kantonsparlament an
für ruedi vonlanthen gibt es noch einen
weiteren grund erleichtert zu sein
es gibt keinen hinweis dass einheimische
am sabotageakt
heilig sein könnten auf der
linksautonomen internetplattform
indymedia bekennt sich eine anonyme
gruppe zum sabotageakt in der google
unter dem titel ausschaffungs lager
kiefers sabotiert bezeichnen die
unbekannten ihre tat als akt des
widerstandes gegen die asylpolitik des
bundes auch die polizei vermutet die
täterschaft in linksautonomen kreisen
dieses bekennerschreiben kommt für rudi
vonlanthen wie gerufen weil er mit
seinem lauten widerstand das klima rund
um das asylzentrum angeheizt habe wurde
er in leserbriefen indirekt für den
sabotageakt verantwortlich gemacht der
linke sieht dass sie gegen die rechte
vordere sitter und zum glück trifft
bekennerschreiben also selber die
linksautonomen sind heute würde nie
sagen dass die linke keine situation
machen um die flüchtlinge schütze vor
der primitive bevölkerung dass ich also
ideen einbringen versorgt sterne würden
dann würde sich entschuldigen über
wirklich auf eine solche entschuldigung
wartete die von landen bis heute
vergeblich
inzwischen hat der bund die googler
umzäunt der zaun soll das gebäude vor
weiteren sabotageakten schützen und
später den reibungslosen betrieb des
asylzentrums sicherstellen
die umbauarbeiten haben begonnen der
bund investiert 8,8 millionen franken
unter anderem in die erdbebensicherheit
zuerst aber müssen alle elemente
entfernt werden
die durch den sabotageakt schaden
genommen haben
es ist februar 2017
zwei jahre nach der
informationsveranstaltung der streit ums
asylzentrum geht in eine neue runde
ein facebook eintrag der asyl kritischen
ig google lässt aufhorchen
sie kündigt an eine bürgerwehr werde
aufgebaut
hinter dem aufruf steht die gruppierung
um den rentner willi america geht news
wo plötzlich hat man darf hier für
rohstoff report.de hause audi salut
d'amour verlässliches von mythos dass
jeder polizist korridors ins könnte
sogar erinnern
zur eskalation führen dass das sehr
schwierige situation ähnlich ein
das ist chabis mit dem cv coaching mit
lätta patroullieren die bürger werden
noch irgendwie besonders mich sie
privatpersonen notsituationen krieg
setzte das gucke was ist los
wenn man das gefühl dass ich aufs ziel
wenn man es kriege ja also brenzlige
situation detailliert 107 also wirklich
starke vordere sofort private vom platz
bis asien
nach einer sitzung mit der polizei und
den gemeindevertretern buchstabiert
diego grad zurück ohne zustimmung der
behörden werde es keine bürgerwehr geben
lässt sie verlauten
während im tal unten die menschen nur
von den flüchtlingen reden sind sie im
sommer auf dem stoos oben bereits
präsent zwei asylbewerber aus eritrea
verbringen einige tage auf der alpen und
[Musik]
da mehr ganz viele bilder darauf zum
beispiel hier was ist das ja auch dumm
nicht sagt man hier genau das ganze
fleisch und das ist alleine wusste der
sportlehrer matthias neuhaus leistet auf
der alps seinen zivildienst er bringt
aller sahins und die wilde de col
deutsch bei die beiden eritrea leben
bereits seit einigen monaten im sense
oberland ob sie als flüchtlinge
anerkannt werden ist offen
kosky der einjährige sohn von marwitz
böschung sowie dessen partnerin manuela
sind heute ebenfalls auf der alb mutter
und kind leben vorwiegend unten im tal
auf der alb haben sich gäste angemeldet
in der küche gibt es deshalb viel zu tun
anna sah und der velde packen mit an
das sah ich wie die zwiebeln die beiden
asylbewerber sind zum lernen ihr einer
erwerbsarbeit dürfen sie nicht nachgehen
welche hobbys hat ihre sätze dass wir
nicht einfach abgelegt sind oder anstieg
bei fremd sondern setzte das dort sind
wir einfach haben
im anderen ort wo sich existenz oder
zusätze das momentane hat seine schafe
zusammen reicht natürlich sind die
geräte ihnen wird die energie die sie
gegen die gegend der art wie wir leben
dass die övag nie verstanden dass es das
virus keine sich die langsam auf
erstaunen doch es gab zwei stück auf
jeden tisch ist das jetzt fertig heute
sind verwandte und familienangehörige
auf die alb gekommen
das schweizer raclette scheint eine
völkerverbindende wirkung zu entfalten
dem sohn von marwitz böschung gefällt es
offensichtlich
[Musik]
am nachmittag helfen alaska und tewelde
beim spenden nicht damit die wiesen
nicht zu wachsen müssen sie von bäumen
und sträuchern gesäubert werden
im monat macht würde zum beispiel die
weder hier die gdp wird der darüber
wacht in einer kurze zitate wir führen
wir für eine gemütliche österreich
mitmachen
von dem her ist das friedenslicht das
heute natur um sie sind sexy dass das
körperliche macht hoffe dass es dass es
so ist wie sie jetzt im zweier schwerer
machen oder hier beim schweizer wo man
die tür und das ist ja dass ich sehe wie
wir funktionieren wie wir leben
[Musik]
moritz böschung sagt bei den
einheimischen finde ein lernprozess im
umgang mit der asyl thematik statt
doch jetzt die diskussion wenn man auch
sehen wie die sich nicht die wandler mit
mit dank die informationen dank dem dass
sie die berührungsängste
dank dem das verdiene lud dreht sich
hier sind das eigentlich von mir aus
gesehen als bloße information und
günstig und informations habe wie
tolerant sind die sense oberländer
tatsächlich gegenüber fremden dominieren
ängste oder offenheit
eine antwort auf diese fragen gibt es
frühestens anfang 2018 dann werden die
ersten asylbewerber in die google ra
einziehen
[Musik]